und wir wechseln jetzt von den usa
zurück zu uns nach deutschland genauer
nach nürnberg hier sitzt sebastian er im
knast was er getan hat ist absolut
unverzeihlich
er heiratete bettina r und missbrauchte
ihre beiden töchter wenn der eigene mann
zum kinderschänder wird
schockierend gefunden dass meine tochter
zeit einen moment der mutter und ehefrau
bettina r den boden unter den füßen
wegreißt sie und ihr mann sebastian sind
frisch verheiratet bettina held das
video für den beweis einer affäre
zwischen ihrem mann und ihrer ältesten
tochter seiner stieftochter
doch es kommt noch schlimmer als sie
ihre tochter zur rede stellt wird klar
es war keine affäre sebastian ehre hatte
die 19 jährige missbraucht und nicht nur
sie auch bettinas mittlere tochter
sie schaltet die polizei ein die nur die
aussage
inzwischen wurde was denn er in nürnberg
verurteilt fünf jahre und vier monate
haft für den kinderschänder bettinas
beziehung zu ihren leiblichen töchtern
ist belastet die mutter macht sich große
vorwürfe
alle kämpfen mit der psychischen
belastung wenn hätte ich den fund von
dem video damals als das geschehene
einfach sport gegeben
zu ihren schuldgefühlen und der
psychischen belastung gesehen sich
finanzielle sorgen
das gemeinsame haus hatten bettina und
ihr mann sebastian erst frisch gebaut
bevor sein missbrauch ausflug unter den
füßen und muss ich dass alle noch mit
mit haken und so war er geschlagen
es ist sehr sehr schwierig